we've been speaking on the program
about the united states as a global
laughing stock under donald trump
this is not just something i say it's
the truth and we have new data
sometimes when i talk about the united
states as a laughingstock under trump
people write in and say david the world
respects trump the world knows
trump does what's best for us and they
don't like that
because we win and maybe they lose
no the reputation of the united states
is in the toilet there's a new pew
research center study
since donald trump took office as
president the image of the united states
has hugely suffered in many countries
the united states reputation
is at a record low looking at the last
20 years if you look at the uk
france germany japan canada australia
in every single one of those countries
favorability
for the united states is the lowest it
has been in 20 years it is at the worst
point now
that it was throughout the entire bush
presidency
obama presidency and donald trump
presidency
right now right now is the low point the
numbers were already atrocious during
the first three years of trump's
presidency
but it is coronavirus and donald trump's
completely failed response
that has really hurt him in the last six
months
only 15 percent of 13 major countries
think the united states has done a good
job handling coronavirus
if you look at a chart of confidence in
the american president over time
among western european countries you see
that
it sort of trended down under bush
trust in the american president was much
higher
in western europe during barack obama
and then it dropped
even lower during donald trump than it
was during the george w
bush administration and it makes a lot
of sense if you pay attention to what's
going on
now very interesting if you look at
trust in trump
versus trust in other leaders across
these 13 countries this is based on
australia belgium canada denmark france
germany italy uh japan
netherlands south korea spain sweden and
the uk
across those 13 countries you see that
the least
trusted leader is donald trump 83
percent
across those 13 countries have no
confidence in donald trump
followed by president xi of china
and putin of russia in other words putin
and xi
are more trusted than donald trump
on the other end germany's angela merkel
is the most trusted at 76 followed by
french president emmanuel macron
and then boris johnson it is not about
left or right
boris johnson and angela merkel and even
macron
are no extreme liberals it is not about
that
the world recognizes trump is a buffoon
who cannot be trusted
they think we're stupid for voting such
a clown
into office remember that trump said on
twitter back in 2014
we need a president who isn't a
laughingstock to the entire world
we need a truly great leader a genius at
strategy and winning respect
that tweet has never been more relevant
than it is today
trump is less popular and less trusted
than vladimir putin
and president xi of china this is a
pathetic joke
but it's a joke that could last four
more years
the whole we should research taking
bleach internally
that was quite a low point even by
applying the most generous standards to
donald trump
and it has been downhill from there and
things are so bad
i would actually ask conservatives do
you really want to defend trump four
more years
or wouldn't you be better off just
attacking biden for the next four years
like from the standpoint of putting them
in positions
of having to defend the indefensible it
almost seems to me that it would be
better for them
to spend the next four years just
criticizing biden
than continuing to defend the absolute
embarrassment that has been donald
trump's administration i don't know
let me know what you think if you are
anything like me
you probably aren't thrilled with the
idea of going into
a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there's a
practical and affordable way to take
control of your health
and get personalized care from the
comfort of your home
it's a service called steady md they're
one of our sponsors
you take a quiz you get matched with a
licensed primary care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour
video call with your new doctor you
establish a meaningful relationship with
them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone
or video chat this is not a random
doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or copays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz see which doctor is right for
you
i took their quiz they matched me with a
doctor who specializes in my particular
health needs and situation the doctor
they gave me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs there's no risk no
commitment to get started
just click the link right underneath
this video